so what do you want to do no i don't  know mate i just think  i just don't i just don't even see how  the whole thing's gonna  let's not even see how the whole thing's  gonna go i just don't  yeah well we're still  you know we're not even halfway through  yet  but two days in i thought we'd get more  done  it's just really really hard with the  whole culvert the national lockdown  we can't get any agents we can't even  get viewings we're just like  banging our head against the wall all  the time yeah  no i understand you feel  so what do you want to do  i don't know  i'm not sure i'm not sure  i don't know  i just feel like he's um  he's just not he just don't want to  carry on doing this  this is probably the hardest um hardest  one i've done man  turn the camera